joe rogan thank you for coming
your first podcast my pleasure tim dylan
thank you for having me i like the way
you do this we come to your studio it's
easy we sit here we do it jamie has to
work extra he's not happy about it but
that's okay
that's all right thank you for letting
me we wanted to follow up lex friedman
with somebody bigger and that person is
you and then
and uh
it's it's i wanted to ask you because
it's been
you know
we were just talking about the hamptons
and how crazy people go
when they have an insane amount of money
yeah you've done very well in the last
forever but in the last year yeah do you
is it weird as a comic the types of
people that you can be around now
or it's weird i'll get like messages
from celebrities like random celebrities
usually about covet advice right like i
get no [ __ ] i've helped like
dozens of people yeah that i've never
brought their names up like famous
actors right musicians
to just contact me for covet advice
interesting yeah it's that's weird but
it's also weird that they can just
they know i know them and i'm famous too
so
like i've reached this weird spot where
i like i feel comfortable meeting famous
people like hi fellow famous person
right whereas
i was plagued by uh impostor syndrome
like for forever like and i would get
real weird around actual celebrities
like i gotta run to the store right hang
out with the freaks you know but now
you're cool with it it's it's more i'm
just more accustomed to it i guess but
the the money thing and the celebrity
thing and all that stuff it is odd and
it's not good for a comedian comedians
are best off
known
but not too famous right because you get
too famous and then you get scrutiny
from people who aren't even really fans
and they start picking up out your
material or looking for you know where
you've aired on the pc side right you
know and where you're not woke or where
what do you think that is with comics
where if they get too much money or if
they're
they get too big a lot of them lose
their mind a lot of them have real big
problems well famous people lose their
mind right it's just a totally unnatural
state of existence right where
everywhere you go people know you and
they're all happy to see you right and
uh then you also surround yourself with
a bunch of people that don't tell you
the truth that's that's pretty common
right and you got to find a way to
mitigate that or you'll go insane right
you have to have something you do that's
like an absolute thing whether it's a
workout thing or you play chess or you
[ __ ] you know whatever it is you have
to have something to that you do that's
really difficult yeah that doesn't give
a [ __ ] if you're famous right if you
don't have like
i look at it literally like
um
like it's a
exercise for maintaining sanity like
this you have to brush your teeth you
have to go work out right but it's not
just you work out to be healthy it's
also work out because it's so hard to do
right that everything else seems easier
right
over the last year you've kind of become
pro is this the most heat
you've ever taken
for an uh position
okay
for about code about the vaccine and
stuff like that is there because i know
that
uh the trans mma thing was big but it
didn't feel this big well the trans mma
thing was big but it wasn't it wasn't
valid it was people that don't want any
criticism whatsoever about trans people
and i was like look i don't have a
problem with trans people right i have a
problem with someone pretending that
they're a biological woman and fighting
women right once you say you're trans
and everybody says okay i'll fight her
fine i'm fine with that and in fact mma
is one of the best places for that
because you know exactly who your
opponent is right unlike like this
swimmer was it you pen is that what it
is i don't know whatever the swimmer is
it's like lapping all these biological
women right that's [ __ ] right because
they don't have a choice they have to
get and fighting is your you're more of
an expert in fighting
than
many things right this is you put your
knowledge of fighting up there and the
knowledge of the advantages that a
biological male has over effectively
they're giant the advantages i don't
think they go away right in two years of
you know hormone treatments and
certainly right it's uh it's too much of
an advantage but if a woman is a
biological woman who wants to compete
against a trans woman i have zero
problems right and there was a situation
like that recently yeah i had no comment
about it right it's basically some
regional level uh fighters and one was
trans and
she was a former like navy seal like
[ __ ] super jack right yeah used to
look like right you know like a savage
yeah and then became a woman and fought
mma and right but apparently it was a
good fight too she almost lost in the
first round one in the second round i
don't care right
my issue's not it's not an anti-trans
position it's like for sure you can't
pretend that that's fair that you don't
tell someone that you were a biological
male for 30 [ __ ] years so 30 [ __ ]
years of having testosterone pulsing
through your system and strengthening
your tendons and your muscles and
changing the way your mind works right
it's a different mind yeah a female
absolutely that's so that was a lot that
was a big one but it was more like i
realized that people will distort your
perceptions on things or your positions
on things this is different this is like
the government gets mad at me right like
this is crazy this is the most
i think i've ever seen a private
individual take
outside of like
somebody who's leaking secrets or
something right i mean this is a pretty
no obviously you're you're you're fine
they're not you know they're not
disappearing you right but in terms of
just criticism
uh you know you know fouchy and the you
know people have addressed you
personally you know like the media has
kind of gone after you personally
does it does it affect you
at all being in the midst of this
shitstorm
on the level you're in it which is
pretty
you're pretty central
well it has to affect you because you're
aware of it if you're aware of it it has
a an effect on you the question is do
you change the way you operate like do i
decide and now i'm going to play it safe
and i'm going to just have podcasts with
athletes or comedians just talk about
silly things right i could do that right
i could just decide to bail out of it or
i could just do exactly what i want to
do right and do exactly what got me here
in the first place so that's what i do
yeah i'm aware of it but i'm like
right
it's i know what's going on too you know
what's going on is one of the reasons
why they go after me is that they
realize i have a lot of influence
another reason why is because they need
a boogeyman like the mainstream media
needs a trump they need someone right
because
on their own the problem is you it's a
lot of it is editorial opinion pieces by
morons like they're really dull minded
folks these are not the brightest well
the reason why they got there in the
first place is not because they're these
courageous pioneering thinkers right who
have like compassionate intelligent
views in the world no they're they're
followed narratives they read
teleprompters and they say things that
align with whatever the ideology is of
their network right so that's what they
do do you have do you have people that
disagree with you on this issue that and
i'm sure you do that you respect yeah
that you go sam harris somebody like
that
people to go
i feel
you because it's a big issue and it's
like a life or death thing
it's an important issue people have very
strong feelings about it
do you like obviously there's a lot of
disingenuous people in the media that
are doing it for clicks but do you have
people in your own life who this is kind
of i don't want to say a rift but like
have you fallen out with people over it
or have you oh yeah yeah yeah definitely
yeah it's um it's controversial but at
this point particularly when i see the
way the government's behaving um the
suppression of monoclonal antibodies the
demonizing of
generic
treatments that are available whether
it's hydroxychloroquine or ivermectin
there's a concerted effort to demonize
treatments that many many many doctors
are using and what countries are using
there's a [ __ ] going on man sure and
then it's brought to you by pfizer right
if you watch
the root of this [ __ ] it's real clear
and so i'm pretty confident in what i'm
saying i'm not saying that you shouldn't
get vaccinated and i'm not saying that
vaccines don't have a positive benefit
for a lot of people they most certainly
do a lot of people who got coveted who
were vaccinated it was way better for
them than not being vaccinated that's a
fact right
another fact is there's treatments that
are available that could stop it dead in
its tracks particularly monoclonal
antibodies the the bite administration
is doing their very [ __ ] best to make
it really hard to get monoclonal
antibodies and according to peter
mccullough dr peter mccall who's the
most published physician in history in
his field the most published ever he's a
rock solid physician without ever having
any controversy in his career up until
kovitt he says there's enough monoclonal
antibiotics for the entire country he's
like they're doing their best to try to
prevent this because if you get that
monoclonal antibodies it stops covet
dead in its tracks so why wouldn't i
early treatment monoclonal antibodies
knocks it d it did it with you yeah you
did it with me right and so then why not
go that route now i know pfizer's
because they want to vaccinate people
they want universal vaccination yeah you
could ascribe
you could say there's all sorts of like
sinister motives for that sure you know
you could say they don't want a control
group they want the entire country
vaccinated so if health problems happen
there's no one to compare it to there's
like there's a lot of things that you
could say there's you could say that
this is just a gigantic money grab that
they have some sort of a very close
relationship with the pharmaceutical
companies that manufacture the the
vaccines yeah i don't know what the [ __ ]
it is but i do know that there are
treatments and in a sane world right you
would be pursuing all these treatments
they wouldn't just send you home right
and say they can't they can't give you
ivermectin they can't give you anything
else they just come back when your pulse
your blood oxygen level drops below 92.
that's not normal right that's not
normal with any other disease right they
have the best off-label treatments that
are available that people are using and
there are randomized controlled trials
that show that they work i don't know if
they [ __ ] work or not i'm a [ __ ] all
right i'm not a doctor i'm not a
epidemiologist i'm not a virologist but
the ones that i've talked to that are
that have treated thousands of people
they tell you time and time again that
these are effective methods they point
to uttar pradesh in india that's knocked
it out using entirely this combination
of ivermectin and a few other off-label
drugs they point to all these different
countries all around the world that have
experienced very low rates of profit and
they say why does japan use ivermectin
why do all these other countries use it
right why is cnn pretending it's
veterinary medication when more people
have taken ivermectin than there are
horses on planet earth right it's
[ __ ] nice the media has clearly
attacked you using a playbook that has
only
made them look
uh
very disingenuous and you've i think
more people's eyes have been opened by
the media
lying about things you've said or
uh misrepresenting uh ivermectin as
horse medication things like that in
terms of i think one of the criticisms
that people have had is they've said
like
why not bring on people that are more
pro-vex i have so you put on certainly
well i had him on i had rhonda patrick
on i had a conversation with her about
it in the early days of the the podcast
i had um
michael osterholm who is uh
he's a infectious disease expert i had
peter hotez who's a vaccine expert right
quite a few of them yeah the the thing
is like over time i've noticed that the
mainstream narrative is being guided in
a way where everybody steps in line and
people are ignoring all these other
things that we talked about
they're ignoring the suppression of
monoclonal antibodies they're ignoring
the suppression of treatments there's a
lot of [ __ ] any of those dudes reached
out to like come back on again or have
they
like asked your home or people like that
is it weird
because also people bring up this whole
thing that you have where you go listen
i'm not anti-backs right i'm not you
have a whole thing where you talk about
like
uh that a lot of people that are against
all vaccinations are are historically
you know they you know they've been
proven wrong like we've stamped out a
lot of diseases
what about like
because i would wonder because this
isn't a vaccine right no no for sure
gene therapy that's part of the problem
yes it's it's kind of an experimental
thing yeah i mean the experiment is
massive now it's billions and billions
of people worldwide right but it's
essentially experimental in terms of
long-term health consequences so i
wonder about guys because they're
they're there's because they don't seem
like bad people
or oster homer guys like that right well
they've never been bad people they've
never been bad people and
are they just looking at well all these
people a lot of them are faring better
with the vaccine if they get covered so
they're not looking at the other
adverse effects there's there's a bunch
of things you could say i mean yeah it's
a lot of it's speculation but again
there's a lot of people that benefit
from being vaccinated that's a fact
right there's also people that have
horrible reactions to the vaccine that's
a fact too like there's a lot going on
and when you're only allowed to look at
one group of
one you know example of evidence and not
another example like one a positive
example versus a negative example yeah
that's not good for anybody no it's not
just sucks for me that i'm stuck in this
weird position you're in this crazy
position as a comedian yeah mma
commentator podcaster but you the show
has become such a massive i mean they
put out numbers the other day i mean
you're the leading media
figure how right now dumb is that well
that's why i know that's why you think i
should be
i was so mad
that you were and i called my producer
and i fired him i had to rehire him
because i couldn't find anyone else but
i was so angry because i don't have
guests and that's what a real media
person should do i have no interest in
anyone's opinion
just like my mother who's a
schizophrenic she never had to have
anyone over to have a good time and
that's the way i do but you now have a
crazy amount of people listening do you
feel because people try to guilt you
people try to go somebody didn't get
vaccinated and they died of covet and
they try to go that's joe rogan's fault
this is what people said that's what
they say well that's what they say i
mean this is their whole thing right
um
this is what i would say yeah why didn't
the doctors give them treatment right
why didn't the doctors get their
monopoly why were they denied monoclonal
antibodies did they request them did
they know about them right you know why
didn't they get iv vitamin drip
infusions why didn't they get nad is
that available yeah isn't that available
that seems like especially uh iv vitamin
drips right that shit's very available
we know that high level vitamin drips
whether it's uh with with especially
with c d zinc glutathione all those
things are like hugely beneficial yeah
any kind of disease people have for sure
i've got them
i've got them like just a health remedy
yeah for the last few years and every
time i do it it feels [ __ ] great and
you know people personally that have had
problems with the vaccine i know quite a
few now yeah now i know over 15 people
right that have had like serious side
effects
both men and women menstrual issues
menstrual issues strokes neurological
disorders chronic fatigue so what's a
neurological decision
your body's shaking jesus yeah and you
can't do anything about yeah like weird
ones man there's and it's the thing is
when you're vaccinating this to be fair
you're vaccinating hundreds of millions
of people in this country alone you're
going to get adverse side effects on any
medication right the thing is if you
look at only that like if you vaccinate
100 million people they they think that
the adverse side effects and they don't
really know because the vares report
it's kind of it's it's very
under-reported and it's also it's hard
to see whether or not the the it's 100
accurate i don't know how much they
investigate individual one right but
if you
they seem to think that at a low number
like a conservative number it's like one
per 1000. so if you vaccinate a million
people you're going to have a lot of
people that have adverse side effects
you've vaccinated 100 people you're
going to have a lot so this is what
we're dealing with yeah and that doesn't
get any play it doesn't they suppress it
there was a kid on tick-tock that uh had
myocarditis and he was a high school kid
like an athlete he was in the hospital
and it got millions and millions of
players they removed it from tick tock
because it doesn't fit the narrative
like that's what's [ __ ] that
is really
an indication
of a much larger problem yes yeah the
problem is they think they're doing good
i mean the 13 year old got in and died a
day later quite a few there's a few kids
that unfortunately you know have passed
away yes i have a friend and one of his
good friends daughter got it she was 14
years old and just immediately
respiratory failure they put her in the
icu she's [ __ ] you know there was one
of the girls in the trials that was 13
years old that's confined to a
wheelchair for the rest of her life and
you know and you can't sue not that
suing would matter when it's your child
no you can't that's part of what's going
on the emergency use authorization it
exempts them from any and you're talking
about these companies that have always
historically lied about adverse side
effects in order to make profit they've
done it with vioxx they've done it with
a bunch of other drugs
pfizer is like one of the most fine
companies russian vaccine sputnik
is actually the best vaccine it's
supposed to be very good it's actually
the best vaccine it's crazy and it's
another nobody's talking it's supposed
to be very good too yeah
yeah the cuban one's supposed to be lex
friedman isn't it you know lex he's an
agent of russia he works for russia he
definitely does and he's here in america
now i think he's related to putin oh
he's certain he's his son
lex friedman is the son of putin and
jaslane maxwell his real name's damian
keep it on keep it on the low but he was
talking about sputnik and i researched
sputnik and sputnik is actually good
yeah could you instead of with the
ivermectin just pitch sputnik well that
way there you can divert the people that
are angry at you and you go all right
i'll give you a vaccine guess just get a
russian one it's the best one
um what's the cuban one called i don't
know it's a good question
james there's a new one that's coming
out apparently that is uh it's an inert
version of the virus like an old-school
vaccine
so that's what you want well i don't
know man i mean is that good is that
good i don't know but it does well
here's the thing man what about
treatments like
what about these [ __ ] treatments how
good is this pfizer pill that's coming
out how good is the merc pills coming
out maybe that's the way maybe they're
great maybe a good thing to do is get
the natural antibodies for an infection
and have a really effective treatment
and also you're right about this you
can't have the body positivity shed no
where you tell people you can be fat and
that it's great for you you shouldn't
demonize fat people but you should also
be very honest with them about you're
making a choice yes just like when you
become a comedian you're making a choice
yes it may not work statistically it
won't but you can try and good luck
right it's like you become an actor an
artist whatever being fat is kind of
similar to that where it's like it's
probably not going to work
long term it's even worse with covet
apparently because there's something
about covet that targets fat and it does
yeah and there's they've shown
significant numbers of people that are
in the icu that are overweight it's
right it's one of the worst things and
in the beginning they weren't as honest
with that right as they are now well
that's the thing it's like there's
things that upset people and so because
they know those things upset people they
don't decide not to talk about right and
you know body shaming is one of those
things right but it's it's it's true
that you have a much higher risk yeah
that's true uh of uh having adverse uh
reaction to covet hospitalization
death if you're a fatty boom baddie yeah
i think if we're really lucky these merc
pills or the fires or pills are
excellent and then also this omicron you
know i've heard i have a friend who's a
biologist who's talking to me about this
he goes essentially what this is is a
live vaccine it's a vaccine that's
burning through the population it's not
he's saying he's saying it's not good to
get it i'm not saying it's good to get
it what i'm saying is it's a respiratory
virus and it's almost inevitable that
people are going to get it because of
the infectious rate of it it's super
infectious
right and because it's super contagious
rather this
disease is probably going to get
everybody who hasn't gotten covered yet
what's driving the entire economy right
now is online commerce
and if you are selling anything online
you need to worry only about
uh cultivating
new relationships
building a client base here's what you
don't need to worry about
shipping
shipstation.com
is your back office it handles anything
if you sell anything online i don't need
to tell you that shipping can be super
frustrating there is so many carriers
and a ton of factors that go into
figuring out the best rate for each
order and with most people shopping
online every year the added holiday
stress doesn't help ship station makes
shipping the easy part of running your
online store so you can get back to
doing what you're passionate about
growing your business
easily import orders from every sales
channel whether it's amazon ebay etsy or
your own website and automate just about
any shipping task all from an easy to
use dashboard again you run a business
your main focus needs to be
growing that business baby
i know a guy
who had a shipping problem and it ended
his marriage
not good you don't want that
you're going to get access to discounted
rates that are usually reserved for
fortune 500 companies
so not only is shipping easy you
actually save money no wonder 98 of
companies that use shipstation a year
keep using it for as long as they're in
business it's that good
it's that good
make this season a little brighter with
shipstation
use my offer code tim dillon to get a
60-day free trial just enough time to
handle the holiday rush for next year
just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter code tim dillon ship station make
ship happen
lucy nicotine is a company founded by
caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative finally tobacco
alternatives that don't suck
researched and developed for three years
to be made for people not patience
lucy has created a nicotine gum with
four milligrams of nicotine they come in
three flavors winter green cinnamon
pomegranate lucy has uh a lozenge with
four milligrams of nicotine cherry ice
flavor each and every flavor actually
tastes great and it's convenient and
discreet
products can be enjoyed anytime on
flights at work on the go even in the
gym
i used to smoke but then i started using
lucy lozages and i haven't had a
cigarette in 20 years
it's 20 21 get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal a subscription to
lucy comes directly to your door each
month so it's simple and you don't have
to leave your house because lucy has
delivery down attention tim dillon show
listeners go to lucy.co
that's
lucy.co use promo code t-i-m
to get 20
off all products on your first order
including gum or lozenges that's lucy.co
promo code tim also i have to give the
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine derived from tobacco nicotine
is an addictive chemical lucy.co
and be sure to use that promo code tim
remember
any company that advertises on the show
is helping the show
so why don't you help yourself and help
the show
lucy.co
promo code tim
what's interesting is that nobody in
hollywood's vaccinated nobody talks
about it we know a bunch of actors
none of them are vaccinated right really
none of them mean they hide it they hide
it that fake vaccine card
no no no no a lot of hollywood actors
are not
doing it because you know
they're younger a lot of them they're
healthier they have access to really
good treatment this is the other thing
um they don't trust a narrative whatever
they're just not and you know outwardly
they're not talking about it right yeah
like think of how many hollywood
celebrities were went hard for black
lives matter
now think about how many of them went
hard for the vaccine not a lot
there's just not a lot of hollywood bear
went home he went hard but that's his
job is it well he's yeah he's a puppet i
mean that's like
the marionette puppety thing i think
i've ever well he's a guy that took the
25 million a year which i get
if somebody pays me 25 million dollars
you know they give him the hosts they
give him a lot of money
and
he was getting no ratings and then trump
came in and he goes i will my aunt loves
stephen colbert you know she's she's in
her 60s or late 50s she has three or
four autoimmune disorders she's
self-diagnosed she drinks white
zinfandel
and she sits in her chair she has a
loveless marriage and she stares at the
tv and stephen colbert comes on and he
goes trump's evil and the republicans
are evil and she cheers and smacks her
seal like paws together and this is how
she's going to spend the rest of her
life
and i have another aunt who does the
same thing but she's a q anon [ __ ] and
she watches laura ingram
and and her husband and her are like you
know it's a loveless
you know marriage and she just sits in
her chair drinking wine watching laura
ingram and tucker carlson
so people at a certain age i think when
they've given up on everything else in
life they get very political yeah that
does happen
gives them meaning gives them something
to do well they watch their tribe go to
war that's like well people are into
football teams that's right you know
[ __ ] go buccaneers
right right these are crazy they paint
their chests yes they go insane it's
their team and if their team loses they
get devastated to you as a highly
productive person
look at people like that and go they're
just lower life forms because i'm not
even nearly as productive as you when i
look at them like that and i i do a
hundredth of maybe a thousandth of what
you do and i look at them and they go
they're like zombies yeah their bodies
and minds have been taken over well they
got it's a trap right it's like if you
ever watch people play three card money
in new york yes and you go oh you
[ __ ] dummy yeah you're gonna get
something yeah yeah like you get sucked
into all these things right you know
that's what i say about like if you get
really invested in politics
voting for president is probably a lot
like rooting on pro wrestling that's
right it might make you feel better but
i don't know how much it really affects
the outcome yeah and they're trying to
pull that back as much as possible now i
mean if you look at biden who's clearly
you know this act didn't get passed
even the democrats are going this guy is
out of it yeah even people that voted
for him are going hey
something's wrong
it it's clear to see
that the the will of the people gets
subverted
a lot
in many different ways sure and the
people who end up running the show
are not necessarily representative
of what the public wants yeah um
and how do you i don't know that you
fixed that i don't know if you fixed
that either so unfortunately
it's just
you end up adopting this kind of cynical
position
right that you can only really take care
of
yourself your family your community the
people you can donate money you can be
altruistic in many different ways but as
far as the government it seems like an
unsolvable problem
it's um it's definitely complex and it's
moving in the wrong direction right you
know i've been paying attention to uh
these companies that are buying up
affordable housing yeah
like black rock and zillow yeah that's
scary it is scary because if they can
move the entire country into renting
like that's right nobody can own it
that's what they want to do right that's
what i'm saying they don't want anyone
to own anything if you get a giant
majority of the population that are just
renters that don't ever own property
they never have their own real real home
yeah and then you make sure that you
control their wage because you have
massive corporations whether it's target
or amazon or whatever and they limit the
amount of possible growth you have
within a company yeah and there was that
article you'll own nothing and be happy
yeah 2030. that is wild and this is you
know kind of you know
when you look at a lot of these
think tanks and you know
groups of very powerful interests
when you look at the kind of world they
want
they would like to get rid of things
like car ownership yes i've been seeing
that too they want to get rid of home
ownership they want people to all be on
the grid in a major way they want
surveillance you know cradle to grave 24
hours a day
seven days a week
social credit systems yeah and the only
thing it's left to do seems to be to to
get in with them
so that when they're doing this to
everyone you're with that yeah you're on
the right side of the place because
here's the problem people are marching
into this willingly they're like
marching into it it's like my aunt or
the other like people as long as their
team wins they don't really care what
rights they lose
and what things end up
looking like yeah they don't there's a
lot of people that don't they and
they're so tribal that if the right wing
people want something they want the
opposite of that even if it kills them
and so i think that there's a lot of
exaggerated positions by people that
take up these really like amplified
right wing positions and it's probably
like russian trolls right or chinese
trolls or something like that and they
take up these positions which force the
people on the left to get even more
crazy with their marxist ideas and
leftist ideas they turn it up they're
being played they turn it up and very
few people are autonomous very few
people
have their own like we're also a silly
country now so we have kids in the
suburbs
calling themselves maoists yeah
unironically
in these leafy green suburbs
and then we have the alt-right and it's
the same kids and they want a return to
the holy roman empire
and these are children running around
the suburbs that are online all day
venerating these genocidal dictators and
going this is a good idea yeah it's it's
a silly country and there's a lot of
problems and you know one of the first
indications that i saw that this was
coming was when comics stopped doing
colleges
interesting yeah because as soon as you
lose the younger people because yeah the
comics are like dude they're too [ __ ]
politically correct right it's too
annoying i don't want to do this they
don't have any world
experience and their their their ideas
are preposterous and you know they don't
want
any they they're like the first to say
no one should own property they're the
first to say that absolutely you know
that we need a redistribution of wealth
right and we need which a little bit of
is good but
you don't want all of it incoming
because then why make money income
equality is a crazy statement of course
because should people make more money
yes yes they definitely should sure if
you look at a corporation that's making
[ __ ] untold billions of dollars and
then you go down to the bottom of the
chain and people are in dire poverty
that are working for that company and
that company is benefiting substantially
it's crazy and that person's the balance
is the battle bounces way off and those
people have no leverage yes that's where
unions come into play that's why it's
important but that's why jeff bezos
recently with amazon like he's taking
the photos with the girl yeah
he's enjoying it at least the amazon
employees even though they don't have
food or healthcare can look at him and
go he's having fun
do you know what i mean whereas a warren
buffett he's just in omaha having sex
with kids quietly and worshipping satan
is that what he's doing come on who who
lives in omaha that has a billion
dollars jake's a lot of coca-cola he's
got a hundred billion dollars he lives
in omaha why because he likes lives in a
small house he says he likes dairy queen
let's cut it out but bezos at least he's
on a raft with these [ __ ]
in the middle of the ocean at least that
inspires people girlfriend i think it's
actually his girlfriend yeah she's
really pretty she's pretty in an
interesting way kind of
there's a shapeliness to her that's she
seems threatening like an animal she
looks like an agent ah kind of like
somebody that would play an agent in a
in a in a movie which is interesting
because she probably is an agent in real
life well she's a massage agent or
something dated a lot of other people
she's had children i think she's
american well god bless her and she's
making good choices i always tell women
if you can marry
a billionaire right marry and move marry
a wealthy dude hang in there for a
couple years then it's way better than
working to marry someone who will
who they make money by destroying
themselves while you enjoy it which is
many relationships that i know
a woman will enjoy the fruits of a man's
liver he will destroy himself
and she will kind of enjoy the money
right bulbasaur's i believe is retired
well he stepped down as a ceo but it's
kind of like putin right where they
never really stepped down interesting
but my
my thing is like
when you have a country that's this
silly
where comedy specials are people
coming out making serious points you
have late night uh host crying
you have you know the girl who
threatened her mother on dr phil is a
legitimate star
right bad baby remember that woman oh
yeah she threatened a killer mother on
tv she's a star now she has massive
instagram following massive massive
where does this go
right pictures of apes are selling for
the cost of a lamborghini
our last president was the guy who
hosted the apprentice and on his last
day of office a mob of lunatics ran into
the capitol
to take selfies with [ __ ] wigs on
it looked like a sketch i would do like
it really is we're we're in like a
[ __ ]
weird movie do you remember when you
were a kid yeah you would hear about the
last days of the roman empire yeah where
they were just like eating until they
couldn't take any more than shoving a
feather in their mouth and throwing up
and [ __ ] everybody yes that's us and
it's
it's everything like that it sounds good
it doesn't sound that bad but it is it
is
funny as a comedian when you when you
step back and you go like this is
really really
crazy stuff it's crazy stuff and the
problem is i don't see a good ending
because if we fall in the other problem
is we have to compete with china and
china has this amazing ability to
control their population through
propaganda and intimidation and
you know total censorship which we're
like moving in that kind of general
direction right which is really scary
because the the one way we may be able
to compete with china is to become more
like china because otherwise like
they're so
they're so integrated
they're
the government and their business is
inexorable they're connected you cannot
have a corporation where the
government's not involved right so the
government makes decisions with the
corporations that benefit the government
and benefit the chinese communist party
benefit the country in general and we're
on that path too
military industrial contractors pharma
companies that kind of killed the obama
health care bill they went in and
rewrote that and they were like we don't
want this all their lobbyists had a lot
of influence on that
it i mean it's strange to
to really conceive of it
as a reality as opposed to just a joke
or a um you know kind of a cynical aside
it actually does seem that we're in a
stage of decline yeah that's somewhat
irreversible
yeah it does it's it's it's hard not to
be depressed have you i think we've
talked about this before douglas murray
he talked about the madness of gender
issues yes well he was on my podcast he
was saying that these gender issues
where people were changing genders
swapping he goes that takes place in all
civilizations that are collapsing now
why is that i don't know is it people
just get bored
i think it's uh
when life gets very easy people start
looking for problems and they start
looking to the structure of society and
then looking to try to dissolve yeah
because there are legitimate
trans people clearly clearly clearly i
know somebody who's trans
who never speaks about it lives as a
woman doesn't even know that i know
great person um born a man now lives as
a woman doesn't speak lives as a woman
doesn't speak about is like well said
very much so everybody knows well i i
don't she probably wouldn't even mind
everyone now is such a fame [ __ ] well
uh blaire white on the park claire white
yeah he's as trans as you can get
you look at that and go oh i get it so
there's 100 but then there's this other
thing where people are going i have
green hair yeah i'm
uh trans or non-binary and you go
wait a minute
hold on a minute
you're a white female who goes to
wesleyan college you're dating a guy
right you're in a heterosexual
relationship
you've felt no oppression your entire
life your dad works for raytheon your
mother's a pill addict
you go to school
and you really joel song this is
and you figure out a way to not be the
oppressor right right you go i will be
different yeah it's true and as a real
[ __ ] you used to have to be a [ __ ]
to be effective like you used to have to
have sex with men or if you're a woman
you have sex with women
and and people
were supposed to you know be like huh
and there was some naturalness to that
because like the reaction of people was
that the thing that you were saying
was real right
and some people were like it was harder
for them to to to get behind and but you
suffered legitimate oppression you
suffered legitimate oppression because
the feelings you had were valid and real
right not non-binary yeah it was it was
it was real like you were saying i put a
penis in my mouth and people were going
that's odd
and was my father said that because
that's odd no i'm kidding
he's he's fine with everything as long
as he doesn't have to work harder he's
not a hard
worker he so the
the whole thing is this new thing has
taken over the gay thing now yeah so
it's not really gay people right it's
fake people are kind of looked at as
nazis
if you see two lesbians now because
lesbians usually own businesses
um
you know they're usually they're
capitalists most lesbians are
capitalists and they're quite vicious
really they fire people
oh most lesbians are very competent
people where is a lot of gay melon
magellan ellen is a
ceo
truly yes she she has a
a real estate portfolio that's in excess
of 100 million dollars i mean she right
the woman was a tyrant yeah but she got
things done yeah but now i think the
gays and lesbians are like the normies
of gays now
and there's a new crop of people coming
in that don't really have any sex
they spend most of their time online
they're all like pansexual communist
witches
and their main goal is to tweet about
you no one even [ __ ] they're really
just tweeting about you
no one's even having dirty sweaty sinful
sex in a motel room anymore everybody's
on reddit talking about you have you
it's a weird thing it's weird for me
it's you know the bird cage the movie it
was very fun yeah i never watched it but
it's a great nicholson may road it's
brilliantly funny
it's gay people in south beach doing
drugs having sex and having fun we are
like the opposite of that we are like in
some sexless autistic horror hellscape
where people just sit around and there's
this weird like office politics
bureaucratic like you know weird like uh
you know you made me upset you made me
upset like i grew up with rent where it
was that show where people were like we
have aids but let's have fun right let's
do it that was the theme of rent it was
like yeah we have aids but let's not let
it ruin the night yeah and now people
are just upset for all kinds of reasons
it's weird and you don't really hate
uh gay people no i don't hate it love
you yeah i don't know you've been
anybody you've been very good to me yeah
loving me
is like golfing with candace owens are
going i love blacks
no i love everybody man
i
i have no ill will towards any
individual group right
individual people of course
silly people how weird is the comedy's
gotten weird like now at the comedy
store you have all these guys that have
talked [ __ ] about you right now
obviously many of them are feeble and
diabetic and dying so it's not like they
present a physical threat i mean many of
them are not well
but
if you were like is it weird now with
this community the way it is that's so
splintered well i don't know who's
talking [ __ ] about me and the ones that
do if that is real
i left and i left i brought a lot of the
people yeah and it's better here right
right you know and i think there's a lot
of fomo going on for sure yeah but then
there's also a lot of people that are
trying to establish this new position in
the food chain which is one of the ways
that you and i became friends right
because i read the thing you wrote about
louie right and i'm like he [ __ ]
nailed it because that's exactly what it
is now he's mediocre talents yeah that
are looking to attack louie who is at
the time and still is one of the best
comics that's ever lived one of the most
brilliant comic minds that have ever
lived and so when they were attacking
him they weren't just attacking him
because they thought that what he did
was wrong right they were doing it
because they wanted to establish that
yeah they want to stomp him down because
he didn't even know what he did yeah you
know like there was just this idea this
very kind of
vague general idea of what what had been
out there and things like that
cowardice and comedy yeah there's a lot
of cowards and there's a lot of people
that take they take some chances but
then they [ __ ] think about them and
they panic
and then they go back and they'll try to
attack someone because they think it
makes them feel like they're more
protected because right offensive it's
like
it's it's it's a wild time man does it
really make sense at the same company
who controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on all your private
conversations at home what about the
idea that a single company controls 90
of internet searches runs your email
service and gets to track everything you
do in your smartphone big tech is more
powerful than most countries are and
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and these tech juggernauts and that's
why i use expressvpn think about how
much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit video you
watch message you sent gets tracked and
data mined but when you run expressvpn
on your device the software hides your
current ip address something big tech
can use to potentially identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertisers expressvpn
also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network expressvpn does all this without
slowing your connection that's why it's
rated number one vpn service by mashable
techradar what i like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protected
stop handing over your personal data to
big tech monopolies that mine your
activity and sell your information
protect yourself with the vpni trust to
keep me safe online visit expressvpn.com
tim dillon that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash tim dillon to get three
extra months free expressvpn.com
tim dillon right now to learn more
you're gonna want the privacy you're
gonna want the privacy you're gonna want
it you're gonna need it
expressvpn privacy
it's a private thing
your life is private when you use this
[ __ ]
the nfl playoffs are here in draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl is kicking things off
with a huge offer counting down to super
bowl 56 new customers can get 56 to 1
odds on any wild card team to win their
game bet just five dollars in win 280 in
free bets if your team is victorious if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet you still have something to play for
this wild card weekend everyone can play
for huge cash prizes with draftkings
daily fantasy football contest
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes with their first deposit
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code tim dillon and get 56
to one odds on any nfl team bet just
five dollars and win 280 in free bets
if your team wins that's promo code tim
dillon this wild card weekend at
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl and a
supporter of the tim dillon show must be
21 or older
new jersey indiana or pennsylvania only
new customers only minimum five dollar
deposit and one dollar wage are required
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler yeah
social media has
flamed up everybody's mental illness
like anybody who had a little bit of
mental illness they just [ __ ] threw
buckets of lighter fluid on that [ __ ]
would you have fouchy on the show 100
wow 100 you don't think he'd come on
though right i don't think he'd come on
but if he did i would request a real
podcast like you can't come on for 20
minutes like we're going to talk for a
few hours what if he came here sat down
got high and was the greatest guest
you've got to be awesome what if he just
admitted it what if he's like joe
let me tell you what about aids yeah
we're making money we made money off
aids we've made money off this i've
gotten to the point i'm coming clean i'm
80. what the [ __ ]
he goes who gives a [ __ ] you just jab
them up a couple of them fall down at a
walmart you are entirely correct tim
that is exactly what i've been doing my
entire career yeah
it's a
he's gonna he's let me tell you about
repurposing hiv drugs
this was how we started a scam
gain of functioning researchers he just
shut it down right yeah two thousand
shut down gain of function research yeah
and he
was like wary of the
implications which makes
he's a smart guy you know how bad do you
miss him when you look at the
president's we've been since i still do
coke with him so i don't miss him at all
i would like to do coke with him and his
wife
hilarious him and bruce springsteen
depressing
i like to come in and spice it up uh
bruce has a podcast with obama no he
doesn't it's terrible that is you know i
should go on and show them how to do it
like stop yeah like you know how they
get like dance instructors that do like
dancing with the stars yes they they
they think they're dancers yes you know
like oh i'm gonna dance no no no the
real dancers are gonna show you how to
dance yeah you and i we should go show
them at a [ __ ] podcast what the hell
are those two talking nonsense oh god
it's nonsense it's all like so like it's
so aware of what people are paying
attention yeah they're so aware of like
walking that line of acceptable
narratives that nobody cares about it
right it doesn't it doesn't work it's
crazy it doesn't work that's one thing
about podcasts the brilliant thing about
it is because there's no real production
there's no real engineering and where a
bunch of people like writing scripts and
following that is that it's so raw that
anything that's not like that doesn't
work whereas like mainstream news is so
produced that if you had raw on main
street news people like what the [ __ ]
kind of unprofessional [ __ ] is this like
bruce springsteen's gotta turn around to
obama during it and be like so your
wife's a man like someone has to
someone has to liven it up
with fun stuff like that which isn't
true but it's a fun one it's a weird one
you know they believe that they do
believe that they're hardcore there's
even do you ever get people that are
with you on the vax but then want you to
go much further oh yeah they're like
listen yeah yeah yeah it's flat yeah
they because they don't stop at the
facts
much further why would you go hollow
earth they they go hollow earth they go
the world is flat reptile people yeah
the jews are in the cupboard
yeah great research yeah
who knows what's real and what's not
real right you go down the list of all
the things that alex jones predicted
right he didn't get a lot of them wrong
well he did it but he did get a few of
them wrong [ __ ] up that sandy hook one
rhymes with mandy mook
and that's a real that was a that's a
rough problem if that one didn't exist
let's let's pretend that he never [ __ ]
that up because he was going through a
rough time in his life he was going to
arrive drinking like crazy he has
essentially a psychotic yes i mean he's
really open about it but my uncle went
through a rough time he just played golf
through it like sometimes
sometimes that's a great point but
sometimes you just gotta go through the
rough time without accusing kids of
faking their death well he wasn't
accusing the kids of doing it he was
accusing the parents whatever he [ __ ]
up he's a good man the point is
if that if he didn't if you just remove
that and then you'd look at all the
things that he predicted
about a lot of them you gotta look at a
guy like people like why would you talk
to a guy like that yeah because first of
all i've known him for more than 20
years he's my friend he is a very nice
guy right he absolutely [ __ ] up but
he'll tell you that he [ __ ] up right
and people [ __ ] up and i think you got
to be allowed to direct the people to do
the harm no no but these are just crazy
his fans are crazy
people some of his fans
are
what they call they're a little off i've
got news for you some of yours are off
too might as well know it yeah i know it
no no avoiding that but the idea that
you're responsible for the off people
that listen to you and want to start
screaming at megan mccain stop [ __ ]
your dead dad well that i tell them to
do
i organize that i have rallies
for sure people are crazy and
they said they wanted to find a
conservative on the view i said let me
go in there with the wig
i'll be the conservative
does any woman even want to do that
anymore nobody wants to do it anymore
you got tim who was a libertarian on fox
they were trying to go hard at her but
she's like i'm on gut felt i'm on a show
people watch who cares they've turned
that show into
what they've done is they've made it so
that all they do is fight right all they
do is scream and yell all they do is get
upset at people it's all negative it's
all demeaning it's all insulting yeah
they've just gotten to this point where
the show has just got this feel of it
you only watch to see who they're mad at
right
no it's it's a horrible horrible
experience
for anyone watching or participating
in it truly this is what's wrong with it
if you got five friends yeah they just
wanted to talk about things like that
and they didn't have time limits and
they didn't know like all these
constraints that are put on a show like
that hinder the the possibility of it
being good
you know this oh for sure all the people
in the audience that's a problem yeah
playing to the audience yeah and then
you have the fact that you'll have a
commercial coming up at 45 seconds you
got to make your point yeah and then
these other [ __ ] are trying to chime
in you've got to talk over them but they
can't find a female conservative no i
think they're gonna have to use that
grandma who was yelling at the sandy
hook parents i forget her name the one
who was like prove it you dumb [ __ ]
but she she's accused of queuing on
grandma i forget her name ben knows her
name queueing on grandma yeah she was
this grandma that was in that
documentary and she would go she would
yell at these parents it was very sad
she'd be like prove it you dumb [ __ ]
about their kids
and i think she should be on the view or
get rosie o'donnell back because she at
least questioned 911 yeah
yeah she um she questioned tower 7 and a
lot of other things like this
that those things are like real
complicated you can't get those wrong
you can't get them wrong yeah but
there's clearly [ __ ] with that yeah
if there's [ __ ] with the vaccine
there's [ __ ] with that well there's
certainly [ __ ] in the reaction to
that because we invaded iraq that's all
you need to know like i had a whole show
at one point yeah it's like if you can
look at what happened on september 11
2001 and then the logical
conclusion is we got to invade a country
that had nothing to do with it it's
crazy it's like it's crazy and then they
did it and they said well there's
weapons of mass destruction there okay
and they cost like more than a million
lives and it turns out there were no
weapons of mass destruction it's just a
weird thing where i go i'm just like one
of those old school guys goes just show
me one video of the plane hitting the
pentagon and i'm good see i think there
is a video of the plane no this looks
like a [ __ ] plane what does that look
like it's a trail of smoke they they
doctored it 911
911 the new pearl harbor is a crazy
documentary by this italian guy massimo
mizuko
it's five hours watch it you people have
nothing to do it's five hours is it good
it's great i'm telling you right now
it's a five hour documentary on youtube
you will watch it get the fam together
sit him down popcorn and i'm telling you
right now because i watched it to debunk
it i watched it to debunk it and went
yeah you start going into the flight the
phones at 30 000 feet these people are
having conversations it's just not
happening something's off you can't
something
something's really really off with that
day but you just can't now in these
publications that write about me they
describe me as like 911 truther
covert denier it's like i just get all
these you had covered how can you be
i've had i've never said
culvert was not real yeah you know i've
said i thought it was good
well i've had people mad at me because i
medicated because i took medicaid
people's argument is you're in shape
you eat right you work out why would you
take the medications because it's better
than not taking medications this stuff
works of course listen i'm not saying
you shouldn't take medication i'm saying
right you're saying you should take
medications i'm saying you should for
sure always but especially if it's
proven medication that works yeah but
the point is like you shouldn't have a
binary solution for things so it's
either this or nothing right it's either
one or zero like that's crazy do you
when people pass away they donate a
large chunk of their fortune to like
research and things like that do you
think you'll donate yours to robert f
kennedy jr or like dana white who will
you give
your money to demi lovato
she's gonna she's gonna give it to
ghosts hey man she used to live in my
building fun woman
um
yeah it's it's straight do you ever
think to yourself what's the next act
because you've literally you're the most
successful comedian
probably when you look at all the
different things you've done
there's not many people that have like
what do you ever go i've done it all and
that's a little scary no no because i
don't think like that ever the the crazy
thing about all the different things
that i've done is i've all i've ever
tried to do like i tried to become a
professional comedian i actually
achieved that and then i started working
as a professional comic and then all the
other stuff is just stuff that came up
whether it's acting on news radio that
was just
they just offered me money do you still
keep in touch with kathy griffin no i
would though no yeah i love her yeah was
she on that show or no
no okay i thought she was on that show
no no no no kathy griffin was on just
shoot me right
it was the other one i forgot she's nice
yeah um uh vicki lewis was on news radio
that's what you're thinking of yeah okay
i don't know i don't know about her
she's redhead too she's that's maybe i'm
getting confused we used to always joke
around that like when she was stealing
her act oh yeah
sitcom that got cancelled that got
cancelled all of a sudden i'm on news
radio working with dave foley and andy
dick and phil hartman with real acting
experience like what the [ __ ] is
happening yeah what's going on and then
i go from that to fear factor i'm like
well this will get canceled immediately
meanwhile it's one of the most
successful reality shows ever it's like
six what did you see what did you learn
from like
that was it just do everything and don't
focus too much on like
because
there's there's there's even though
you're saying you're stumbling into them
and you are stumbling into them there's
a skill to stumbling
right there's a skill to being
position yourself in a way that you can
kind of get those opportunities there's
that but there's also being able to
handle pressure okay like being able to
handle auditions pressure being able to
handle the pressure of uh speaking live
in front of a large audience whether
it's uh doing the ufc broadcast or doing
a comedy show or a podcast you gotta be
able to handle pressure right some
people just suck at pressure you know i
always put myself in these positions
where i have to perform under pressure
because opportunities are available
there because so many people don't like
pressure so i look at our go oh they're
scared people are scared of this so i'll
go do that right there's less people
doing it and there's it's more exciting
to me because it's kind of dangerous
it's scary when you got into it was your
family like oh this is cool or were they
like no what are you doing what are you
doing idiot yeah go to school get a
career right a real job like you're not
funny right there was a lot of things
right right when i was fighting like
you're gonna get hurt yeah there's like
everything i've done like what are you
doing you know it's just
it's hard if you have a child and you
want your child to be successful you
don't want your child to take some wild
crazy [ __ ] chance that what is a
million to one chance it's gonna pan out
probably more than a million dollars
right was your childhood like to show
cobra kaya netflix where you're just
fighting people all the time
that's what i imagine it is you're just
you're in a dojo you have a sensei you
just fight the other kids at the at the
you know um well i did fight a lot of
people but yeah i did it mostly in
tournaments but i did fight in dojos a
lot we didn't have everything dojo
fights not that i know of okay
why were you fighting everybody were
they fighting you yeah yeah yeah we like
guys would come in from other schools
and
challenge us
and i was often the guy who got thrown
in with them yeah
when you were younger were you bullied
what motivated you
yeah yeah i was small and uh guys would
pick on me and i moved around a lot like
we moved all the time like i lived in
san francisco from well new jersey to
age seven san francisco age seven to
eleven florida 11-13 boston 13-24 so i
was talking move and concepts right so i
never really established a great group
of friends that i was tight with right i
was always the new kid and i was not big
so i got [ __ ] with right so you
learned to defend yourself well i had to
when i when i moved to uh
to newton i got [ __ ] with like by a
bunch of kids and it was kind of scary
you know i didn't know how to defend
myself and i was like [ __ ] like i got to
do something and so i started taking
martial arts and it changed my life 180
degrees like
turned it around 180 degrees right then
also i wasn't worried about conflict
anymore and then i became obsessed with
being
like oh like a world champion i became
obsessed with being did you have like
one good teacher where there's a few
good teachers
yeah i had quite a few but i went i got
very lucky that i went to this one
school this jay hun kim taekwondo
institute in boston it's like one of the
most
uh highly respected schools in the
country at the time at least and it was
just dead lucky just dead luck i just
happened to go there one day right and i
happened to go there while this guy john
lee was training for the world
championships and i happened to watch
him train like when he was at his peak
of condition when he was a national
champ and and i became obsessed right
and i was there every day right so most
of my my high school from like age 15
all the way until i was 21 was just
obsessed with martial arts and competing
right traveling all over the country
that's mostly what i did and your
friends i guess were people
in that world yes yeah some of them like
my friend steve graham i'm still really
tight with yeah and
how do
what makes you go from that to comedy
well it's kind of an interesting fear of
brain damage right there was a little
bit of that because i was i was
definitely aware that i was getting hit
in the head too much it was def
especially when i started kickboxing i
had uh three kickboxing fights and when
i was training for kickboxing which i
did for
more than a year there was a lot of
getting hit in the head there was a lot
of hard sparring rounds and then i was
also watching a lot of other people that
i saw that had brain damage i was like
uh
like this guy's not who he used to be
like he's slipping and then i realized
like oh my god this is happening to me
and there was no money in it right there
was no ufc back then so this is 1988
89's when i feel like you gotta get out
yeah i had to get out yeah and i had to
get out soon before i ruined my brain
you know and then also fortunately my
friend steve that i was talking about
earlier
he was one of the people that told me i
should be a comedian because i would we
would go on these trips to go to fight
in tournaments right right oftentimes be
on a bus or we'd travel by car together
and
we'd be bored and i would be the one who
made everybody laugh and so like if we
were like getting ready to spar
everybody would be
like super nervous and i would say the
most inappropriate [ __ ] right and get
laughs out of people and once i knew
that i could get laughs then i would
just try to do it right whenever i knew
people were nervous i would say the
inappropriate thing or do impressions of
people or impressions of like uh our
instructor having sex right so you just
established yourself as kind of the
funny dude it was silly yeah absolutely
and it was like it was gallows humor
right everyone was so scared and it was
also it would alleviate some of the
pressure of like getting scared before
you go to a tournament we're all scared
right you know and so my friend steve
said you really should be a [ __ ]
comedian yeah i go ah man you think i'm
funny because you like me i go other
people going to think i'm an [ __ ]
right and he's like i don't you should
just you just go and just see an open
mic night and try it and so i did i went
to an open mic night and were you hooked
on night one yeah pretty much yeah
richard jenny had a great point yeah he
goes horrible comedians are amazing in
that they inspire people to try it
because you look at someone who's
terrible and you go well i can't be as
bad as that guy right i'll give it a
shot right that's what open mic night
was to me right i had thought of stand
up like jerry seinfeld or richard pryor
i thought like i can't do that these
guys are too good right then you go to
open mic night and you go oh
some of these people are terrible right
and they're doing it and like i can kind
of do it like they're doing it maybe a
little better than them maybe maybe i
could do this and then on the same night
like there was like jonathan katz was
the host of the open mic night from uh
miss dr cass in boston yeah he was the
host of open mic night the first time
everyone on stage and then on that night
some other real professionals went on
like teddy bergeron went on yeah i got
to see him go on and i i got hooked
immediately yeah so i did my first set
and then i almost chickened out i got
really close to chickening out oh my god
i came that close to pussying out yeah
and then um once i did it i was hooked
and then i started doing it all the time
and you got successful pretty quick
pretty quick yeah i mean luckily in
boston you could get work pretty quick
right you know so like within one year
of doing open mic nights and you know
and we i mean fitz simmons and i started
out together and we would draw greg and
i would drive together to rhode island
to do 10 minutes right so we drive 90
minutes to 10 what year was that 88 wow
yeah we both started in 88 we both
started with like within a week of each
other so you would go to comedy
everybody smoking cigarettes oh yeah it
was
you know old school oh yeah yeah bars
were not improv comedy oh yeah yeah
there was no idea like there was no
non-smoking right right yeah
just everything everything else like
that yeah and everyone smoked right it
was crazy and people would just you
would you would go up do the 10 minutes
yeah
sink or swim
killer bomb and then you would be back
on the road yep and then we would try to
go to different places like we would go
to a couple different spots at night if
we could you know sometimes we knew
another guy went in another room did you
know back then would you look at certain
people and go that guy's gonna make it a
lot of people i thought we're gonna make
it that didn't and what what do you
attribute a lot of that to why do you
think a lot of funny people because i've
seen that now i've been doing it about
11 years
probably almost 12 years now a lot of
people i was like that person was really
funny yeah and they didn't get to that
next level i don't know man yeah i don't
i mean i think a lot of people just
drinking
that that's one a little too much
sometimes drinking or driving that could
be it but it's also there's psychology
involved yeah
the um the mind games that
that the unknown and the uncertain play
on people some sometimes people just
crack i just can't take it anymore just
like we were talking about fame yeah
people crack under fame like they get to
a certain point where they can't handle
this anymore they can't crash they don't
know what's real right they crack under
that they crack under uh the pressure of
not knowing if they're gonna make it i
mean i've seen that in actors too like
i've been friends with actors that were
like they'd get on a show and then you
know they'd audition for another show
and then maybe not make it but maybe
have like another callback for the thing
and they're always in flux and it would
they would go crazy because they didn't
know like what am i doing with my life
what is happening is this going to work
out am i and they'd start crying
freaking out it's like right just the
uncertainty in the unknown for some
people it's just too much it's too much
some of them are really [ __ ] talented
some of them are really funny and then
there's a lot of people
that are somewhat mediocre but they have
mastered the unknown
yeah like that's delusional yeah there's
crazy people out there that have
that can channel that
into certitude yeah and then they start
convincing themselves like they've
convinced himself they're great
and then they start convincing everyone
else and it's kind of like the emperor
has no clothes where everyone's like i
guess they're great well i don't even
know about that but one thing that some
mediocre people do is they're not funny
at all but they've managed to stay
around right like here they are 10 years
later 15 years later he's still here
he's still going up hosting that show
still doing it still doing it yeah do
you hear do you think people that are
starting comedy now
are is it going to be a completely
different world
where i i tend to think now
people that are starting are going to
have to go to the internet
and and almost the same way
that you were taking a beating at open
mics and things like that
they're almost gonna have to take a
beating online
in front of a digital audience to build
their thing because the
the mainstream or the legacy industry
seems to of comedy seems to be dying so
even though they'll be getting good at
stand up on the side
if they don't have other components what
do you mean by the mainstream of comedy
meaning that the idea of moving to new
york or la and doing 20 sets a week
and then getting the montreal comedy
festival and then getting the booker at
the club to see you unlike you and then
getting a special on hbo all that seems
to be dying i know so many people with
our specials and nobody's watching them
right or so many people with late night
tv shows like they're hosting them and
no one cares yeah that's true and and
they're not making that much money and
it seems to be a smaller and smaller
circle of people that this is mattering
to
every day the internet's expanding it
seems to be getting bigger and bigger
and the people that have a platform
online a digital platform seem to be
getting more and more attention so to me
isn't there an
inevitable shift coming to where comics
really are just gonna have to compete
digitally i think the digital aspect of
it is the best way to promote themselves
for sure right whether it's through
putting their stuff online on a youtube
or a rumble or
instagram or whatever they're doing like
we're getting
on your own that's a news story why is
it not news chinese party now i believe
yeah why are you it's a news story that
you're on getter well the news story is
their their [ __ ] amount of people
that signed up increased by 1 150 or
something yeah you have like 20 you have
like 9 million followers on getter yeah
it's not real though isn't it because
scanner doesn't even have nine million
people no really yeah yeah it's it's
very it's so there's [ __ ] with that
this is where the [ __ ] is they take
all my twitter followers so i my twitter
follows like 7.8 million yeah and then
they port those over so i started out
with 7.8 no
so whatever i have now if i have eight
it's like really i have two hundred
thousand so get her yes fugazi
as they say
and every time i post on twitter it
posts automatically on getter oh
interesting yeah it's like it's
automatically done yeah so it's just
harvesting your tweets and i don't know
how to get off like if i get off a
getter
you you have to i can you have to sit
down with marjorie taylor green
personally and she's got to tell me all
about what's in the basement the common
pizza she's gotta take you down the
rabbit hole then you come out the other
side of ghetto
but yeah it seems to me that like the
business is kind of dying i don't think
it is you don't think it is no no i
disagree i prove it is this no no no the
that aspect of the business as far as
like montreal comedy festival and stuff
like that being beneficial that's true
that's dying right but podcasts have
taken their place right comedians now
like brian simpson who's got his newest
brilliant netflix one of the best yeah
he's working with me this weekend
one of the best i love him to death and
he now that he has this huge netflix
special that killed and he's been on my
podcast a couple of times he's got a
career right he's killing it right he
will continue to kill it yeah so this is
where the the but he's not as big as
rambu
so my point is that who's that rambu's a
minecraft streamer joe stop pretending
you don't know who he is is that real
yeah he's a minecraft streamer my point
is that
things are moving quickly we can't
compare ourselves to minecraft i
understand that but
i'm just saying
yes we can
i
disrespect has a book
mr beast has a burger well mr beast
deserves a bit he's a brilliant guy he's
got a crazy good it's a great show yeah
he does he does he's a visionary it's a
smart thing that he does he spends a
shitload of money on his show well
that's what i mean these are the new
stars well that's jesus
those are the new stars in terms of like
that would be he would be a reality tv
star
like 10 years ago for sure now he's a
youtube star but now he's his own
[ __ ] boss and he's doing it the right
way which is why it's so successful the
same thing with your podcast imagine a
world where an executive bankrolls your
podcast and says oh are you going to sit
together with your friend ben and you're
going to wear cop sunglasses yeah are
you going to talk [ __ ] about the whole
world yeah what are you talking about
you want me to pay for that i could
think of several executives that would
fund it but they're all disgraced
angelo mozilla with country ride dick
fold at lehman brothers exactly
the world has changed but there are new
avenues that are available right but
the world of comedy remains in clubs
like you yeah that is true you gotta be
able to get on stage and play and we
both yeah that is the most important one
of the most important things yes it's
like i'm not giving that up like stand
up no one's [ __ ] awesome and yes that
is always going to be a thing that i
like to see and it's always going to be
a thing that i like to do and it's
always going to be a thing where people
want to go see a comic they want to go
live it's a fun thing to do don't you
want to get to the point where people
know you so well from the internet that
when you get on stage they just clap for
45 minutes you don't even have to write
material and then you can just leave you
can kind of wave like princess diana
used to do i don't think that everything
happens i don't think you ever get no of
course not i feel the heat after about
15 minutes of course i know of course
you do i get nervous as soon as i walk
on stage
i get the mic i got i
no it's the biggest high you ever have
it's the best thing it's the best art
form it's also the best thing for the
audience like in terms of like it's the
most audience member yeah i love
watching someone kill it's fun that's
right when i laugh hard like i'm
laughing hard it's only killing but
you're also from a generation of people
that leaves their house that's true
there's a whole generation of people
that are scared to leave the room well
let alone the house my audience
you have to keep evolving you should be
on twitch you should be streaming i'm on
spotify you're a young man
you can keep going where's my deal what
did they tell us [ __ ] off for the ninth
time all because i'm telling you to
[ __ ] i could attack the ceo i said he
was a pedophile it was a joke that's not
real no one can have fun anymore i think
he said i'm a pedophile too yeah i'm i
don't know if i did that but i said that
the ceo
was uh something or other but he's so
he's mad at you no he's not mad but
apparently because they have you they
don't need me yeah because we have
overlap and they're still going by they
should get you they're still going by
the old numbers that say that this
show's bigger than mine those are the
old numbers this last week this show's
not even on youtube anymore i keep
telling them it's true it's not even on
youtube they go oh no it doesn't matter
we have the internals in your bed
honestly the the beautiful thing about
spotify has been the lack of censorship
and the lack of fear of having episodes
pulled and all that [ __ ] modified has
been amazing and in the beginning people
thought they were going to be worse than
youtube they've actually conversely been
so much better yeah there's been so much
better i think that's just because
people always they
they hate change they hate any kind of
like that's right thing that's happening
and you know also it's like they hate
they hate someone doing well so someone
gets something it's a crazy deal and
they're making all this money like uh it
sucks now i used to watch now i hate it
yeah [ __ ] it's the worst she's sold out
normal it's normal so and also
in the beginning i did lose a lot we
lost like 50 of our audience like almost
right away yeah jamie was in a frothy
panic really look at him well he's got
so many other opportunities frothy panic
yeah uh but a year later we've got as
much if not more we have more right and
it's better it's bigger than where it's
ever been you just it just had to like
this is just what happens immediately
i'm just like good let me be ten percent
less famous right right happy for 25.
give me 25 less fame yeah and more money
well that's not the way it's worked out
yeah well that's funny you're like let's
be a little less controversial a little
less famous
and then on the other side of it you
have fauci trying to drone you outside
of your house
it didn't really work for him now yeah
oh my god you think so oh yeah
yes they hell you and nail you like the
cuomo's well that's a different
situation right the fouchy situation
after rand paul attacked him for gain of
function research and then people
started looking into game of thrones
research and it all came from josh
rogan's reporting and josh rogan he was
the one who showed that
fauci
funding the eco health alliance that the
nih funding them is what started up gain
of function research in wuhan like after
obama had put the kibosh on it yeah and
he's like still in denial but the nih
has come clean nih has said yes it's
gain of function research and fouch is
like gain of function research is a very
nebulous term like he talks so slow he
gets lots of diseases the guy's a
problem it's amazing he is like the way
he handles where he's obviously cornered
right and he just like
jiu jitsu's his way well he's also been
a government
uh guy forever forever he's been a
bureaucrat the highest paid government
employee yeah and he's paid more than
the president yeah and they did a
documentary about him and it's he's very
vain the documentary about him is the
reason they took the thumbs down off of
youtube it's crazy how vain
how vain he is of course you know and
how
you know unwilling he is to give up the
spotlight even when as you showed me
that hugh hewitt clip
people are like you know you might
accomplish the goal of getting more
people vaccinated by stepping aside yeah
because you're not well liked or trusted
and it's crazy to watch them react to
that yeah you're crazy you're crazy i
completely disagree yeah it's my show if
you criticize anthony fauci yeah you're
criticizing science would you have billy
boy gates on 100 yeah yeah 100 i think
that would be interesting i'd say how do
i get in the club yeah what do i have to
do well it's about that time you're
you're knocking on that door how do i
get a yacht dude what if you just
reversed everything you said tomorrow
like it would be kind of hilarious turn
around if you just went in here tomorrow
and go you know i slept on it
and i've decided i got double backs last
night yeah you go i got double backs
last night shots at the same time i had
a great sleep
uh and i have the ceo pfizer and
modernity here and hillary clinton yeah
and we're all going to tell you
everything's okay yeah yeah maybe that's
the move does it scare you
to be
at the level of prominence you are
with like a family
just the idea of like
as the kids grow up and they hear things
on the news does is it harder for you to
explain
to them why is what i do yeah i mean
it's it's not easy to explain but nor
would it be easy to explain if i was a
hit man you know it's like well those
aren't the only two options that's how i
live
i have one
one or two choices
either i go out like the punisher
right i mean i like that but so do they
ever ask or is it or they not yeah they
think it's funny like but they think
it's funny because i think it's funny
that's right like when i come home like
daddy's in trouble again right oh the
the the government's mad at daddy yeah
you know like
they don't if i i guess if i really
tweaked they would probably tweak too
but you set that standard of like this
is part of the job part of this man you
know and you know it's that
if you can't take the heat expression
you know right you shouldn't be in this
business right absolutely it's the
business of opinions you know we're in
the business of opinions yeah and it's a
weird [ __ ] business because people
it's hard for people to have opinions
today because of corporate structures
human resources you know you want to
make it up the corporate ladder and
there's an ideology that your company
has and if it's left-wing or right-wing
you have to toe that line like it's
[ __ ] hard for people to just have
opinions and even if they do have
opinions when do they have the time to
talk about it that's right the thing
about talking about opinions like we do
when you sit and talk for hours and
hours nobody has the time to do that
what have you learned i think through
this whole period not only just the last
year but the last few years about
the way that
friendships work
uh at your level because everybody wants
something from you right
you have this platform
um you can share it with people
everybody wants to get on the show
everybody wants maybe you to endorse
their i have friends who call me they're
like yo tell joe about this weed
opportunity i'm like are you
on drugs and they are but
like how do you deal with just that
whereas all these different people i
have to say no to a lot of things you
say no to a lot of people and sometimes
yeah and sometimes it's uncomfortable
like sometimes people won't let it go
and you know and you said people will
comment you all different ways friends
your wife everybody's just trying to get
in there yeah yeah it's it's it's uh
it's an issue you know i mean i changed
my phone number a lot right i've got to
change it again you know right changed
it last year i got to change it again i
i have several phones i have four phones
now i used to have three now i have four
that's crazy no i have a b c and d
you're a congratulations oh congrat
thank you very much i appreciate the fun
i carry
but there's a lot of people that i'll
check their i check that phone once a
week right yeah and maybe not even
sometimes not who's the best guest
you've had other than me in the last
seven or eight years would you say
there's so many good ones man yeah is
there anything i mean so many serious
ones stands out
is peterson
yeah classic yeah he's awesome
bob lazar oh yeah that was great that's
a great episode you know i don't know if
he's
mike tyson
mike tyson's gray i've had a lot of
great ones elon elon is always great and
alex yeah alex is great yeah i've had so
many great ones so many comics like one
of the things that we've been doing is
uh me shane gillis mark norman and ari
shafir we do this thing called the
cuddle party yeah where's the four of us
we get [ __ ] hammered i talk the most
[ __ ] and then afterwards like panic like
maybe we should cut that part out oh
that's the best that's when you know
it's good
that's when you know an episode gillis
was hammering we've only had one person
and it was giannis papa's come on our
show where we couldn't use any of it
because he just starts attacking
screaming about ali wong i mean he's
he's mentally ill
we love him but he's meant he's unwell
and we know this had too many heroes
yeah and so we just couldn't use it but
god love them um
the uh but yeah those are when you know
they're good episodes well it's
those but those with the ones with
comics are my favorite because i feel
the most at home i mean look i i wear a
lot of different hats for lack of a
better term when yeah this when i do
this thing it's very strange like
sometimes i'm talking to a scientist
sometimes i'm talking to someone who
wrote a book about the environment
sometimes i'm talking to a psychologist
sometimes i'm talking to a comedian
sometimes i'm talking to a fighter
sometimes i'm talking to an inventor
it's like it's a weird gig man yeah and
it's only
me
that's booking them it's right like like
that guy looks like fun how do people
get on people ask me all the time to go
how does somebody get on that i seek
people out i said yeah i think i'm like
he just has to want you to come on yeah
that's it there's no other way on right
it i have to say yes like there's
literally no other way on because well
there's also giving me twenty five
thousand dollars
and what that'll do is increase the
likelihood it'll help it'll help yeah
but it's not an i've done that once
really yes i didn't take the money but
he paid a friend and he my friend was
broke and he told me hey this guy told
me that if i get you on or if uh i get
him on your podcast yeah he'll give me
twenty five thousand dollars that was
the exact number
and i said listen i said i would have
that guy on anyway because he's really
interesting right yes so you can i love
you so you take the money yeah and then
i'll have them on but i would i'll just
let you know i would have had him on
anyway but don't tell him that and get
that money good for you but yeah there's
no one
there's just you have to be interested
in what somebody is saying that's one of
the beauties of the podcast is that
it's only what i'm interested in so
whether it's talking to bob lazar or
talking to a fighter or talking to an
artist you know like people like it's
only right i have to be interested and
i'm like uh i'd like to talk to that guy
or oliver stone who was on today i was
like oliver stone wanted to come on and
i don't know if you've seen his new
[ __ ] kennedy doctor it's amazing holy
[ __ ] it's good i haven't seen it but
it's [ __ ] amazing and there's a four
it's on showtime right now until the end
of february at the end of february it's
everywhere and he's going to release a
four-hour version wow yeah it's [ __ ]
fantastic so this leave will leave no
doubt that it's oh my god there's no
doubt
go let's get them let's do it sure
that's what it is
yeah and that's one of the reasons why
the podcast works is because there's
never a moment like you remember that
bill hicks bit about jay leno sitting
there talking to joey lawrence and his
blood splatters like the nbc peacock
yeah he's a company man
and yeah but it's that jay leno really
didn't want to talk to these guys right
that's the bit like hey joey lawrence
yeah yeah you got a girlfriend what's
going on
maybe yeah yeah yeah you know you talk
to people you want to talk to exactly
like there's no one gets on unless i'm
so much of the rage i think it you is
that you've really found this way
to monetize enjoying stuff
and satiating your curiosity and having
these long meaningful conversations and
you've revolutionized the long-form
discussion yeah and all of these other
media figures that supposedly could have
done it or fancy themselves to be
intellectuals and to be
none of them did it you did it a
comedian an mma commentator you did it
none of them did it it's weird so i
think a lot of the rage at you comes
from that
it's that you took a chance on yourself
and it worked out and none of them did
well it's it's weird too in that
um
like when it became a long form just
because that's what i wanted to do like
ari was like the [ __ ] most adamant
person telling me you gotta change it
you gotta edit it
tell me like you know i'm telling you
right now you're [ __ ] up i go how am
i [ __ ] up he goes you gotta edit your
show it's too long i go well then don't
listen right
i love that when he goes people won't
listen you go they don't have to yeah
i'm like i don't care yeah i was making
no money right i was making zero dollars
i was doing it every week yeah and it
got to the point where
there was one time when me and red band
were sitting around he goes do you know
how many downloads this gets yeah well
no and he goes the app still got a
million downloads and it was like like a
record skip yeah
what what yeah what a million downloads
ari has great advice he told me once
that i should i should put out a tweet
about kobe bryant and i didn't
so thank god but just so sometimes he is
wrong sometimes sometimes he's wrong
yeah uh he's a funny guy
uh but he's have you ever seen his dick
and balls
every day
he's watching him stay at my rental and
taxes his videos
all he does is is expose himself
indecently his
his balls don't look like they'll belong
with his dick i told him that his balls
seem like his dick is a hermit crab and
he stole his balls from someone else and
they're living inside of it
he's he's completely out of his mind
you're my best friend
i'd say you're here with me in spirit so
happy new year look at those balls
it's insane they're so big it's like
elephantitis
they're like
like a giant chimp yeah like you know
chips yeah
it's like elephantitis yeah it's crazy
that's what it's like how does a family
like texas love it they love it yeah
they love it they love it yeah man it's
[ __ ] great here yeah people are so
much more relaxed and my what i think is
really important what i'm doing here
with the club and yeah the podcast here
is um i'm completely removing myself
from the influence of hollywood right
because when you're in la you're still
you're still in it it's still it's
contagious yeah it's in the air you're
like oh i got it on me like that
disingenuous [ __ ] right for you know
that fake sort of behavior that they do
that stuff gets into our business yeah
we have those actor types that kind of
like they they dance in both worlds and
yeah they have like one foot in the
actor world
foot and then they'll tweet about stuff
yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing why are
you talking about that right because
they're in these both worlds and that
world it contaminates things right and
comedy
needs to have its own center where it's
like comedy is the 100 percent the thing
it's not comedy to become a sitcom star
right i want to tell young comics and i
want to help them and say hey you don't
have to do anything else right you can
just do comedy you don't have to have
anybody hire you for something right you
can be completely autonomous and you can
have all this
like freedom to do podcasts do other
people's podcasts and we all will work
together as an organic network yeah you
can just practice stand up right which
is what everybody loves right everybody
loves stand up you do those other things
because you think that's what you have
to do for a career yeah but ultimately i
remember being on news radio i remember
being on this fear factor in particular
and seeing people that i knew that i
started out with they were killing it in
theaters and they were on the road all
the time and i would be jealous right
and i'd be like god i wish i was doing
that yeah i was trapped not trapped
obviously it's a good trap yeah but i
was doing a show and i was like i can't
travel yeah i have this show i have to
do all the time yeah i could travel very
rarely and i remember thinking god this
like cements in my head that i really
love stand up i love money it's not
money what's what's nice about money is
you don't have to worry about money
right because if you don't have money
then you worry about money but if you
can have a clear head
and once you get money don't think oh my
god i hope this doesn't go away now i
have to play everything safe and i have
to i have to really play by the rules so
i get more of this hollywood right
instead what i did was going okay good
now i've got some money now i can just
be free now i'm gonna just do what i
want to do yeah and then
the
podcast thing came out of that because
it was completely organic there was no
thought whatsoever about it being
profitable zero yeah and the club you're
gonna open in a few months and yeah a
lot of people will come
probably you know to the club from other
places too well because you have a huge
fan base and people will come the goal
is to be as supportive as possible to
stand up community right to make an
awesome place where comics where
audiences can come have a great time
comics can come and know they're safe
we're going to have fun there
you know we're going right maybe you are
going to require the booster everyone
gets boosted
before you go on stage every time i
think if you just i think there's a
waning period where people like well the
vaccine effectiveness has dropped off
maybe if you keep hitting people will
come back yeah just boost them every
[ __ ] week and maybe if you die you
are supposed to yeah i mean people are
always saying that the roads are too
crowded here for sure what if we boost a
lot of people yeah
i mean that makes a lot of sense i want
to thank you for taking your time i
pledge you guys ben's going to get you
we promised you 50
uh ben go to the atm get him the money i
want to thank you yeah i want to thank
you for being one of these new
up-and-coming people that's very
exciting and i think you're paving the
way for a lot of people that are seeing
what you're doing wow
you're courageous you're a wild
[ __ ] you take chances you're
smart it's awesome well thank you for
doing this i'm happy to be your friend
well i am happy to be your friend and
thank you for giving me the strength to
be a gamer and be trans
[Laughter]
good night
thank you
thank you joe